hello how's it going my name is mark
i thought it was only appropriate since
we had 30 million subscribers that
i would adopt the stash so uh
that's what i did
uh
kind of on a whim you know it's so funny
i i play so many characters with
mustaches that
actually having this
doesn't look too out of place but also
but anyway happy 30 million subscribers
thank you so much for uh
making this milestone possible thank you
so much for making this possible making
this feel completely natural and normal
you know how i said that uh videos were
going to be back to normal and i was
going to be
you know back on schedule well about
that it turns out that even after uh
filming is done for space which it is
done did i mention that it was done
it's done did i mention that it's done
but also even after it was done there
was a lot more to do in terms of
post-production and editorial but i have
good news because
i'm going home
in just a few days i'm very excited
about that and why i'm excited is
because i have not been home and able to
dedicate myself to just normal videos
for about five months
and that's not a joke
legitimately i have not been home
and able to focus on just making youtube
videos for about five months and also
ignore the
pimples on my face i seem to be
going backwards into puberty i got this
mustache for a reason i thought i'd be
mature yeah but i i left for canada
around april
16th i think and it's now september 19th
i have not been home for a long time
i've been doing a lot of other projects
i've been filming a lot of things and so
um
getting back home is kind of
exciting for me because when i get back
home i don't have any other big projects
on the horizon i really don't you know
i've been doing
i've been talking about these for so
long and i still have a lot of work to
do with them but
i'm going home yeah god five months away
is way way way way way too long it's not
like i haven't been making videos in the
meantime i have and i've made some fun
ones but i haven't been able to focus
100 on them so
when i get back
i'm going to be in complete health my
foot is not broken because that happened
right before i left if you guys remember
that i'm just really excited about i
keep looking at myself in my camera just
because of the mustache it's really
throwing me off thank you everybody so
much for 30 million subscribers thank
you so much for being with me
like for so long i know it probably
has been kind of frustrating with videos
not getting up or at least that's how
it's been for me like not getting videos
up is is just kind of the most
aggravating thing because it seems so
simple but i don't want to make just
simple videos i want to make fun videos
i want to make videos that i'm proud of
i want to make things that i'm proud of
and so when i'm off making bigger things
it's like i kind of satisfy that itch
because i'm like oh well i'm taking the
time that it needs to make something
bigger and make something better but at
the same time it kind of like gets at me
because i'm not able to make the smaller
videos that i also want to make bigger
and better i want i just want to make
everything bigger and better but you
know time anyway that's pretty much it
thank you everybody so much for watching
back back to the stash cam thank you
everybody so much for watching
thank you everybody so much for watching
um
yeah i just am very very eager to
do all the things
but also i'm very grateful for being
able to do the things that i want to do
i can't cover up the stash and just um
yeah thank you
guys so much for
being a part of this channel for so long
and uh
seeing it grow with me as i grow and you
grow it's and it's
it's an experience that i never could
have imagined doing
when i was growing up but now that i'm
here
i just never want to take a day for
granted you know so i'm not going to do
that and when i come home
get ready because it's going to get
weird
that's always been weird all right i'm
gonna go
you can stay if you want to the video is
going to end but you know you can just
like leave it on the freeze from you can
pause it here and you know you just you
just enjoy this shot of the stash
you